Donald Trump, we have now learned, thanks
to Bob Woodward's book Rage, supposedly bragged
about a secret nuclear weapons system when
he was speaking to Bob Woodward during these
interviews that took place over the last six
months for Bob Woodward's book.
This is according to excerpts from the book
that have been released.
Trump talked openly about a weapons system
with Bob Woodward that is supposed to be secret.
And this was in the context of telling Bob
Woodward how close we supposedly were to war
with North Korea nuclear war in 2017, which
is a whole horrifying nightmare in and of
itself.
And according to the excerpts that The Washington
Post has published, Trump told Bob Woodward,
quote, I have built a nuclear a weapons system
that nobody's ever had in this country before.
We have stuff that you haven't even seen or
heard about.
We have stuff that Putin and Xi have never
heard about before, saying there is nobody.
What we have is incredible.
And then in the book, Bob Woodward goes on
to say unnamed sources that he spoke to and
said, what?
What is Trump talking about here?
Sources did confirm the existence of a new
weapons system to Bob Woodward, but they said
they couldn't share any details.
And they expressed surprise that Donald Trump
actually mentioned it to Bob Woodward because
he wasn't supposed to.
The Hill then reached out to the Pentagon
for comment.
The Pentagon said they don't talk about books
that have not yet been published.
And when The Hill did more investigation into
this, they spoke to, for example, James Acton
from the Carnegie Endowment for International
Peace.
And what James Acton said is this probably
is a submarine launched low yield nuclear
warhead and its existence is now known.
But the details remain classified.
This is so.
So there's two sides to this.
One is we shouldn't even have this stuff.
We need nuclear disarmament.
And maybe Trump spilling the beans will help
build that case.
The other side is Donald Trump is just so
irresponsible with classified and secret information.
And he criticized Hillary Clinton for that.
And he criticizes Adam Schiff and Chuck Schumer
and Nancy Pelosi for that.
And yet it's Trump who has the record of bragging
about new weapons that are publicly unknown
or semi known and disclosing details.
Remember the thing about the supersonic missile
that goes superduper missile that goes 17
times the speed of sound or whatever?
Remember Donald Trump in the Oval Office spilling
secrets from an ally to Russian spy recruiter
Sergei Kislyak on and on and on.
But on the tail end of this.
It's not new that Donald Trump is irresponsible
with information.
And much of it is because of his narcissism,
which I will got to consider that Donald Trump's
kids have access to a lot of this information.
Who has Jared Kushner told about this stuff?
What has Ivanna done or done, Junior, with
knowledge of these things?
And this is the classic attention seeking
behavior of a narcissist.
I've known many serial liars in my life.
They're very toxic, very, very toxic.
Sometimes they straightup for attention say
things that are lies.
I knew someone I remember was that.
My glasses are five.
Dollars another not, and if they were, I wouldn't
even care.
Just they want attention and they say straight,
straight up lies.
Others will say things that are true but that
they really shouldn't be talking about.
Sometimes narcissists will in order to get
attention.
They will reveal a secret that a third party
told them that they really shouldn't be revealing.
As an example.
And that is that that is part of what Donald
Trump does.
And he does his fair share of lying as well.
Imagine the things he's told people that we
don't know.
He's told people.
And imagine what our adversaries are quietly
doing with that knowledge.
This man is a danger.
He is a danger.
And he may get four more years if we don't
do the right thing.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
Glad you're with us today.
Remember, next week we're on vacation.
The show is OK.
We're not canceled.
We're just going up going on vacation next
week.
But we've
still got a full show today.